[Musica]
[Applauso]
uno dei miei sogni
quando ero bambino era quello di
diventare pilota di elicottero
l'idea di stare con le mani la testa il
corpo su un mezzo sospeso in aria tra le
nuvole
mi ha sempre affascinato in realtà la
vita poi ti porta a percorrere strade
diverse
diametralmente opposte in alcuni casi
come il mio io ho fatto infatti un po
alla fine dello struzzo sono finito con
la testa sotto terra
faccio il biotecnologo del suolo ovvero
mi occupo di studiare tutto ciò che vive
sotto i nostri piedi la biodiversità del
suolo e per farlo utilizza la biologia
molecolare ovvero lo studio del dna
ma partiamo dal suolo questo è un
termine che non sentiamo molto spesso
perché per indicarlo si utilizzano
parole diverse come terra terreno
inoltre quando lo sentiamo quelle poche
volte molto spesso ha un'accezione
negativa facciamo a una mamma papà che
vedono il loro bambino la loro bambina
per rientrare in casa con le mani oi
piedi sporchi di terra
la prima cosa che gli dicono è corri a
lavarti le mani pulisciti bene
figuriamoci immaginare qualcuno che
possa studiare il suono se io mi abbasso
guardo vedo una superficie piatta
solitamente di colore marrone inanimata
cosa ci sarà mai di tanto interessante
da studiare lì sotto in realtà il suolo
si è osservato da un'altra prospettiva
non dall'alto verso il basso ma da
vicino di profilo ci potrà sorprendere
la prima cosa che emerge agli occhi è
sicuramente il colore i suoli non sono
solo maroni ci sono centinaia di
sfumature di colore del suolo
si va dai suoli neri tipiche tipici
delle zone delle torbiere ad esempio
ricchi di sostanza organica ai soli
bianchi tipici delle zone desertiche
ricchi di calcare
si passa poi dai suoli
ricchi di ferro e di colore rosso o
giallo presenti nelle zone tropicali e
poi ovviamente sì c'è il suolo marrone
lo troviamo ad esempio nelle foreste nei
pascoli soprattutto nelle nostre zone e
le nostre latitudini
forse per questo siamo abituati a
pensare a quel colore a quel colore lì
cioè cambiando il colore cambiano le
proprietà del suolo
cambia il suo ph il contenuto di
nutrienti di sostanza organica
cambia anche le proprietà qual è la
fertilità ma soprattutto cambia la
componente biologica la parte viva sì
perché se osserviamo un solo da vicino
il suolo risulterà essere tutt'altro che
inanimato un suolo è vivo e ricco di
biodiversità
quando parliamo però di biodiversità del
suolo
molto spesso ci vengono in mente un paio
di specie simbolo la talpa il lombrico
se ci sono assolutamente innegabile
in realtà la biodiversità del suolo però
è molto di più sia in termini di colori
di forme di dimensioni
si va dal mondo microscopico è
rappresentato da funghi e batteri che
sono i veri dominatori numerici del
suolo in una manciata di suono possiamo
contare centinaia di migliaia di specie
diverse di questi microrganismi fino al
mondo macroscopico hanno presentato si
da insetti come le formiche all eternit
i e poi anche piccoli mammiferi di cui
la talpa è un esempio ma sicuramente non
l'unico e poi c'è tutta la terra di
mezzo in cui è rappresentata da specie
meno note ma per questo non meno
affascinanti importanti come ad esempio
acari e zoboli
bene allora guardando tutta questa
biodiversità forse il mio sogno iniziale
di avere la testa fra le nuvole posso
dire che in parte
l'operato si dice infatti che esistono
più specie sotto i nostri piedi che che
stelle in cielo e il paragone credetemi
non è azzardato infatti un quarto della
biodiversità sul nostro pianeta si trova
sotto i nostri piedi e di questa una
larga parte è ancora da scoprire
solo il 5 per cento dei funghi che
potenzialmente esistono sono stati
descritto quindi c'è veramente
un mondo da scoprire sotto i nostri i
nostri piedi
e per farlo a differenza delle galassie
e delle stelle che si trovano a distanze
impercorribili e sufficiente abbassarsi
e raccogliere pochi grammi di suolo per
poi iniziare a studiarlo come studiare
però la biodiversità del suolo
qui la tecnologia negli ultimi anni
sicuramente ci ha dato una grossa mano e
ci sta infatti un elemento che accomuna
tutte le specie ma al tempo stesso delle
rende uniche
sto parlando del dna grazie alla
tecnologia oggi è possibile di fatto
sequenziare il dna di qualunque
organismo dal più piccolo batterio al
più grande albero ma non solo
e possibile anche sequenziare il dna di
un ambiente di qualcuno in
quell'ambiente quando dico qualunque
intendo davvero tutti
si va dal nostro intestino pensiamo
tutti gli studi sul microbioma
intestinale a una goccia d'acqua a un
grammo di suolo e il dna ambientale che
è studiato da una scienza che prende il
nome di genomica ambientale o
metagenomica è rappresentato dalla somma
dei dna degli organismi che vivono in
quell'ambiente
se io quindi vado a leggere il dna di un
ambiente andò a caratterizzare la sua
biodiversità
bene allora sappiamo che sotto i nostri
piedi
c'è tanta vita e ci sono dei modi per
studiarla fra la domanda potrebbe essere
a me cosa interessa sapere che quel
determinato suolo vive quel gruppo di
funghi o di termiti
beh la risposta è abbastanza semplice
perché la biodiversità del suolo e utile
ci sono sempre più studi che dimostrano
come i servizi offerti al genere umano
dalla biodiversità del suolo sono
molteplici
io mi farò tre esempi il primo il cibo
pensiamo alla frutta e la verdura che
troviamo tutti i giorni nei nostri
scaffali del supermercato bene se li
dobbiamo dire grazie anche a dei
microrganismi del suolo sono infatti dei
funghi che vivono in simbiosi con le
radici delle piante che avvolgono in una
fitta tela e aiutano la pianta ad
estrarre i nutrienti e l'acqua dal suolo
in questo modo la pianta cresce meglio e
con lei i suoi frutti che poi arrivano
sulle nostre tavole
quindi la biodiversità del suolo ci
aiuta nella prodotto
del cibo secondo gli antibiotici è uno
dei problemi caldi in questo momento per
la medicina e la ricerca di nuovi
antibiotici perché quelli che conosciamo
sono sempre meno li usiamo troppo sono
poco efficaci qui ti pensate o a tutti
gli organismi che vivono nel suolo per
per sopravvivere il devono letteralmente
combattere tra di loro uccidersi quindi
e per farlo producono molecole
antimicrobiche antibatteriche ecco
allora che il suolo potrebbe essere una
fonte inesauribile di antibiotici e
questo non ci sorprende perché di fatto
già gli antibiotici che stiamo
utilizzando come ad esempio la stretto
micina che prodotta da un batterio che
forma delle colonie che ricordano un po
la muffa sulla marmellata arrivano
proprio dal suono
ecco allora che la biodiversità del
suolo ci aiuta anche nella ricerca
biomedica
terzo il cambiamento climatico i periodi
di siccità stanno aumentando sempre di
più e con esse la sofferenza di
ecosistemi come le foreste dove le
piccole piante in carenza di acqua
semplicemente non sono in grado di
sopravvivere si è visto che in presenza
di un gruppo di organismi del suolo le
termiche che come le api e le formiche
vivono in una struttura a casta con una
regina e con delle operaie e dei soldati
al suo completo servizio bene si è visto
che in presenza di questi insetti le
l'ambiente e l'ecosistema è in grado di
reagire molto meglio alla siccità
questo perché il suolo rimane più umido
la decomposizione più alta e quindi le
le piantine sono in grado di
sopravvivere facilmente ai periodi di
siccità e coloro che possiamo dire che
la biodiversità del suolo ci aiuta anche
a combattere gli effetti negativi del
cambiamento climatico
ma lasciatemi fare un passo in più
quando pensiamo alla protezione della
biodiversità in generale pensiamo delle
specie simbolo come ad esempio il panda
tutti piace il panda e una specie che
trasmette tenerezza e bello
beh lasciatemelo dire anche la
biodiversità del suolo si è conosciuta
ci potrà sorprendere da questo punto di
vista è bella presenta delle varietà di
colori che non hanno nulla da invidiare
con quella delle piante
oppure una tenerezza e un candore che
non hanno nulla da invidiare rispetto a
dei cuccioli di animali
anche per questo penso che la
biodiversità del suolo vada conosciuta e
protetta la necessità di proteggere la
biodiversità del suolo è dovuta al fatto
che sempre più minacciata non solo da me
minacce che sono tipiche anche nella
biodiversità sopra il suolo come ad
esempio la deforestazione o il
cambiamento climatico ma ci sono anche
minacce tipiche del suolo e della sua
biodiversità
un esempio è l'erosione ovvero la
perdita di suolo a causa di eventi molto
intensi di piogge molto intense in
europa si stima che ogni anno vengano
perse 900 milioni di tonnellate di suolo
a causa di fenomeni di questo tipo e con
essa perdiamo anche la bio bio diversità
allora il fenomeno così intenso così
preoccupante ci deve portare a muoverci
ad agire e questo è quello che facciamo
al centro comune di ricerca
proviamo a mappare la biodiversità
perché per proteggere qualcosa il primo
passo è capire dove quel qualcosa si
trova così nel 2016
abbiamo pubblicato la prima mappa
globale nella biodiversità del suolo
come vedete in europa non c'è così tanta
ricchezza di suolo soprattutto se la
paragoniamo a dare come l'amazzonia
o piuttosto che la l'africa equatoriale
tuttavia è necessario la mappa la
mappatura perché la biodiversità del
suolo essendo complessa e molto
difficile da mappare e la mappa infatti
che abbiamo fatto è tutt'altro che
completa è un primo passo è un inizio la
metà genomica ci sta aiutando a cercare
di colmare le lacune e le dimenticanze
questa mappe verranno poi utilizzate per
sviluppare delle normative ad hoc per la
protezione della biodiversità del suolo
ma prima della ricerca scientifica e
dello sviluppo e dello sviluppo di
normative che consentano la protezione
della biodiversità del suolo
ci siamo noi e la vita di ogni giorno
noi che dovremmo iniziare a interessarci
interrogarci raccontare parlare di suolo
e di sua biodiversità
dovremmo veramente provare a creare una
cultura del suolo che al momento manca
dovremmo imparare a conoscere il suolo e
la sua biodiversità a non temerlo a non
vederlo come qualcosa di sporco
la biodiversità è bella la biodiversità
è utile la biodiversità ci consente
veramente di fare molte molte cose
proprio per questo dobbiamo giocare col
col suolo far giocare i nostri figli con
suolo sporcarci letteralmente le mani è
questa sera vi lascio con un altro sogno
mi piacerebbe che una mamma e un papà
quando vedono il loro bambino la loro
bambina entrare in casa con le mani
sporche di terra o di suolo meglio in
questo caso utilizziamo il termine
giusto non gli dicessero corri a lavarti
le mani ma gli chiedessero ti sei
divertito hai trovato qualcosa di
interessante racconta meno grazie
[Applauso]
[Musica]